like one of my one of my goals one
something this is going to sound crazy
and this is the perfect the perfect
audience to say this but like I get so
jacked up about the idea of like
toppling a DCT dictatorship one day I
get so excited by it and I'm like I'm
not even
[Music]
kidding all right look at what I have on
my head there we go oh look at that look
at this guy Wow you went from dad to
cool dad in one episode with that hat
I'm hip I'm hip you had the shirt too
did you buy like a full uniform or are
you actually just working there now or
what Jonathan got the hookup and he and
he got a swag bag from them and he gave
came over to my house the other day and
gave it to
me and have you gotten any compliments
or like do um anybody under the age of
like 25 recogniz you now or something a
few a few a few young people one young
person said called me cool
guy that's all the affirmation you're
looking for now as a dad get away from
me cool
guy
hey why why you staring at me cool
guy did you need
something that's how it was uh you want
to kick us off who do we got all right
we got Patrick in the house Patrick's
been on before so the OG listeners know
all about Patrick Campbell PC as he's in
my phone he uh created a company called
profit well sold it for 200 million
bucks he's got the background that we
always talk about where I'm like I
noticed that people who have this
background tend to be winners more often
than not he was a competitive debater uh
some would call him a master debater
he's a um he was in the the NSA the
intelligence agency so he brought last
time you were on you were telling us
about all the crazy you did to
gather intelligence at as uh in the
startup world so like how do you learn
about what your competitors are doing
and whatnot and now today he's back with
a bunch of ideas and um I want to know
what you've been doing because you sold
your company for 200 million bucks and
then you had a bunch of time on your
hands and that's a deadly combo uh you
sent you sent us something I want to
start with this uh thing you texted us
about the Bezos number and I don't know
too much about it so I want you to
explain you go I've been I've been
working on I've been searching for my
Bezos number I don't even know what that
means explain what is the basos number
yeah totally so here here's the thing as
this started from a premise so sold a
company basically um working at paddle
and also thinking about like what the
next thing looks like and what I found
in the ideation process like I haven't
come up with ideas in like 10 years I've
helped like companies come up with ideas
but it's just one of those interesting
aspects of the entrepreneurship journey
and my big belief is your job as an
operator is to basically know your
customer and know your space better than
anyone else and you need to do this
before you start building because a lot
of entrepreneurs fall into this trap
where we're really good at willing stuff
into existence because that's our job
except it's relatively easy to do that
today so this means that like basic
ideas are cheap mostly indefensible and
worse they waste a lot of our time and
so the first step I come in terms of an
ideation process is using this Bezos
number framework and basically when Jeff
Bezos started Amazon he noticed this
like crazy stat you know this new thing
called the internet was growing 2700 per
per year um so you knows he's got to
build something on it um he didn't know
what it was but he was starting from the
trend because when you go where the
water's flowing as they say and ride a
wave you don't need to be like a genius
to figure out what a really cool
business looks like so I have this doc
um and I'm happy to share it with the
audience where myself and a researcher
basically call through industry reports
Trend and Stat websites um and then the
hack that no one really probably uses
but they should use um is we use Google
Scholar and other academic kind of
publishing sites uh to find all these
Trends because in Academia you have a
lot of like undergrads and grad students
basically writing a bunch of papers
about here's what's going on in the
space Here's all these numbers that are
going up or down um and then I put this
into a spreadsheet and then basically
label a couple of different you know
categories one in particular is like
what's the doubling time of this
particular Trend um as well as like how
long or how fast this trend is going
what the causes are what the effects are
and the basic idea is then I can find
like hey the world needs something in
this space or the world's going in this
direction and partially I can figure out
like oh this is something that I could
get paid for kind of in that eeky guy
framework that you like Sam um I can
basically take that by looking at these
Trends so let's describe this sheet so
basically it's like category so you got
like social issues Health Care energy
right so that the big categories then
within each one you have a trend and so
like for example a trend would be top
college admissions rates are dropping so
and then it says Stanford admissions
went from 4.8 to 3.9 in The Last 5 Years
and Harvard dropped from 6% to 4% in The
Last 5 Years um so then it says
Direction you know decreasing uh in five
years you know what is the kind of rate
that this is happening what's the
doubling time so like how many years
would it take for this to this trend to
uh the where we're at today to double
based on that rate and then here's the
sources and possible causes and possible
effects of it and so you have I don't
know like a hundred in here basically uh
let's read a couple of these out I want
you to to kind of Riff on on a couple of
these or you can pick maybe what what
does it mean when it's in blue does that
mean you like that one or something or
what does that mean uh those are just
some some interesting trends that we've
gone deeper on basically all right let's
do this random one I want you to talk
about this number number of coral
bleaching events I don't even know
really what that means what is a coral
bleaching event and why does that matter
basically Coral is uh you know dying out
um you know essentially when there's
like stressful um conditions Coral ends
up like bleaching so this particular
idea like I don't know what a business
could look like in here and that's not
the point necessarily of like the Bezos
numbers is like I'm not necessarily
trying to find like one particular
business I'm trying to find an overall
trend right because some Downstream
effects of this could be there's more
money that's from the government from
regulation basically going into
protecting you know International or you
know National Waters and there's a bunch
of different things that are why is
coral bleaching bad okay well let's go
back to your high school biology uh
class I didn't know that's what I would
be teaching today but um the basic idea
is like you're killing off ecosystems in
the ocean right that's probably the most
basic way I can say it and there's a lot
of Downstream effects when an entire
ecosystem basically falls apart and the
coral is a major part don't act like I
should know this man 90% of people 90
95% of people listening to this do not
know if
Coral it's beautiful coral it's alive
Coral it's part of the underwater
ecosystem and it's like the butterfly
effect you just take away big part of
the ecosystem it's going to have all
these like secondary effects on the fish
do you care about fish Sam or do we need
to explain why fish matter I do not care
about fish look you guys Sean you know
about don't don't get get off your
here's the point Sam Sam here's the
point the point is we're looking for
major Trends and those major Trend like
you ran a basically a trend Service
website like you understand the nature
of Trends what I'm looking for in a
particular idea is I'm basically looking
for really really fast growing Trends in
One Direction or another because that's
where essentially as I was saying like
the water is going to continue this
Coral theme and basically if I can ride
a particular wave I'm hedging
essentially all these business decisions
that I might be making Downstream from
it got it so pick another one on this
sheet Patrick that you find interesting
that you you kind of have noodled on a
little bit Yeah so there's I mean the
obvious ones are like interest in AI
these types of things but like some some
less obvious ones might be around the
kind of like the social issues right so
right now A really sad one to kind of
talk about are like school shootings
right so I don't know if you've looked
into this particular Market not
obviously increasing or you know school
shootings but like there's an entire
Market that has been created around this
because of the rise of that particular
happening now you can get into kind of
like the government dynamics of like gun
control and stuff like that but like
there still is the fact that schools are
looking to like not only make their
students feel safer but also their
parents feel safer so there's things
like bookcases that fly in front of you
know doors there's things like clear
backpacks there's an entire Market
that's kind of propped up against this
and when you see this particular Trend
you can then think through the second
and third order effects to essentially
come up with is this something that
hopefully you can you know obviously
help the actual Trend go down but also
you can make sure that you can build a
good business around it I have a random
question why don't they just make put a
certain thing in the gun that like you
know for example we have metal detectors
which is like we're trying to find a gun
but there might be other metal there
should just be a thing in every gun
that's like a detectable thing that you
can now if if you're a security thing
it's like oh we're always looking for
this certain compound of lead because
that's intentionally put chipped into
every gun that's sold so that it can we
can easily identify hey a gun just
walked through this door uh so a metal
detector is that basically what you're
saying or but not metal I'm saying metal
will catch all kinds of metal I'm saying
they should put something that's unique
in every gun in the mold of every gun so
that it can be detected easier than
looking for all metals and slowing
everybody down for like keys in your
pocket got Sean your your your
California is showing coming out yeah
you you I thought you were going to say
something that they can remotely turn
off all the guns in something happens FL
the gun hey it might even be a status
symol like it beeps it's like hell yeah
I'm packing right who knows I'm not I'm
not judging I'm just saying we're
covering the environmental global
warming debate and guns that's what
makes my first dud I was just flying so
I went through TSA like three times I
went through Disneyland security i' I've
just been thinking about how do we make
this faster because it's a very slow
process yeah yeah Imaging is actually
getting really really
good I can find this client info have
you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
align no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow
better you you have another thing on
here that is interesting and I think
Scott Galloway talked about it was and
i' never I didn't see the stat until
just now teenagers not having sex so you
said that um it's doubling every 9 years
it Rose from 11% to 2 1% of teens that
do not have sex that that haven't had
sex in the last year um that's kind of
interesting I think that Japan if I mean
you looked into this more than I Japan
has suffered from this and isn't there
like a like an idea that like in the
next 10 or 20 years Japan's population
is really really really going to be
hurting for this lack of procreating
yeah well there's there's a lot of
countries where that's going to happen
even China they're talking about you
know a pretty big collapse um and so
there's a lot of again causes for where
this is at and I'm not an expert on like
population design or anything like that
but I do think that this is something
that's really big not only amongst just
teens in general but also amongst young
men um who are kind of you know
basically checking out of the ecosystem
and this is like a pretty big problem
just for the economy in general let
alone like procreation and fertility and
stuff like that and so this is kind of
an interesting space where like yeah you
have a social issue or like you know
cultural issue that's kind of driving
things in One Direction are there like
private solutions to kind of quote
unquote solve this particular problem um
you know cuz at least in America we're
not going to do what you know China has
been rumored to be doing you know with
kind of like the reverse of a two child
policy like these types of things and so
yeah it's just this is one of those
Trends as well that's like worth going
deeper and deeper on to see like what's
going on not only make the world a
better place but like see where business
can be and this cost of cyber crime one
that's one of your fastest growing ones
what's that yeah so basically um the
amount of damages from cyber crime so
this is not only things like targeting
old people you know for fraud but also
this is things like um you know a DDOS
attack on a particular website or for a
company um basically cyber crimes
exploding um and it's probably going to
accelerate even further with AI Beyond
this like 7x 5year magnitude that I have
in the spreadsheet um and so yeah that's
that's something that's really
interesting because you don't really
have good solutions for it um you have
everything from like Aura and some of
these like kind of VPN identity
protection products um but on the
corporate side there's been a lot of
money that's sosed in there but it's I
don't want to say it's obsolete but it's
changed dramatically with like the birth
of AI and all that kind of fud that's
happening with that market there was one
there's a couple on here that um we've
seen people come on this podcast and
talk about specific businesses they
created off of these Trends so for
example um you have sports betting
revenue and uh it's the doubling time
you have on here is less than one year
so you said it was legalized in 2018
it's it's already 4.3 billion in the US
right now so and that's a five year
fiveyear span to get to about 5 billion
in revenue on on US legal sports betting
and it's still only legal in what
Patrick I don't know if you know the the
details but it's only legal in a couple
of states right it's not like yeah it's
it's it's there are more States I
believe that have legal marijuana than
they do of sports betting so it's but
it's it's getting a little bit
easier the the rumor is and again not an
expert on this in particular but the
rumor is is that there'll be a lot more
states that come with this before the
other states kind of legalize marijuana
and so those are both markets that are
really interesting because it you know
gets into all the vice Market kind of
dynamics that you see with a lot of
those different of companies we the guy
we sold uh the milk road to two guys one
of the guys had this interesting
backstory because they bought it with
their own money and not they're not like
a company they didn't raise money and so
we were like where where are you getting
the funds to make this size purchase and
they were like well you know here's our
backgrounds and one of the guys had a
fascinating background so he was a a
affiliate marketer so he basically would
make like content sites for online uh
poker and online poker was legal for a
while then Black Friday came online
poker is no longer legal in the United
States so it's like business died
overnight and so what every he was in a
really competitive space of all night
poker Affiliates because it was like a a
just absolute Cash Cow to be a poker
affiliate because somebody's going to
immediately go deposit money and you
would get your your fee for that and so
when they killed it in the United States
out of the 100 competitors 99 said well
I guess we'll opt for international
traffic now that's the only answer yeah
he just took a different approach he sat
there and he looked he's like well okay
it's illegal right now in the States but
is it going to be illegal forever
probably not and he kind of waited and
he's like he was just patient and he saw
a little Trend pick up where the um New
Jersey was rumored to be uh be the first
state that was going to legalize it
again or it was going to legalize uh
online gambling only for if you lived in
New Jersey and uh and I think the way it
worked was like there was like local
casinos that could have online portals
to for you to gamble on and so when
everybody else went International he's
like I will now be the New Jersey
betting affiliate and he created his
website was like I don't know what it
was it's was like betting in new
jersey.com or something like that like
very hyper targeted sounded so Niche um
it sounded almost like a step down but
what he realized was if one State's
going to do it and then the second state
started to get rumored to do it he's
like oh this is a trend I just want to
surf I'm going to start now and make all
the content for this for the states that
are rumored and I will be the best
position when the time comes as this as
this accelerates and so he did the New
Jersey one he sells it for I think it's
publicly out there it's like 42 or $46
million to a bigger Bing company and
then he just he's like oh cool
Minnesota's coming next he does the
exact same thing and does it for
Minnesota sells that one for another 40
something million and to the same
company uh like within a like sort of
two-year time span and then that company
was smart and they they're like hey uh
okay now this covers like all states you
can't just do this you can't just keep
flipping these to us for 50 million a
pop and so he basically made like a
hundred million selling the same
business just looking at the data and
the trend and the news and realizing
okay this is going to happen it's just a
matter of timing uh this this wave now
and he was the only one that was really
paying attention to that and it was him
and one other guy and they just merged
and so they became they be they then
owned all the supply so they could jack
up the rates as an affiliate um which
normally is other problem with
Affiliates they get put under pricing
pressure but because him and the other
guy merged they could go demand whatever
rate they wanted to anybody who wanted
customers because they were the only
only show in town um the other one you
have on here is popularity of French
bulldogs so you say it's uh doubled in
five
years um and bu French Bulldogs are now
the number one breed of an in the uh AK
the American uh Kennel Club um which is
like a published database basically and
so our friend Ramone kind of did this
with wiener dogs he was like oh like
look at how popular these groups are how
fast they're growing on Facebook of
people who own wiener dogs and he's like
what's a pro then he started
brainstorming like what's a problem in
the weener dog space and he found this
company that was making ramps for wiener
dogs to get on and off of beds and
couches and because he saw the
popularity of these groups and how Avid
the owners were how fast those groups
were growing how big they were he knew
there's a market for Wier dog ramps
which like if you walk into Harvard
Business School and you're like here's
my big idea they'd be like you're nuts
uh you know you get laughed out of the
room but that business was doing you
know whatever 20 million a year because
he was able to like correctly identify
the right Trend he scaled it I think
from like 300,000 a year to like 17
million a year in like 20 months or
something like that yeah it was insane
but this is why like again
ideation is it treated a little bit more
like a science than just this random
like listening to podcasts YouTube
videos and like having a notebook
because there's a lot of these ideas
that like I couldn't tell you what a
good business idea is in them but if I
start to think about it further and
further that's where like really good
ideas come from right so the French
Bulldogs right like I don't know what
the pain points of French Bulldogs are
but similar to remot story there's like
something very interesting there either
directly or like sitting around that
particular idea that could be really
really interesting so basically we've
all seen with AI people can now it's
like generative AI you can create an
image or create a video from just a
prompt or from you could deep fake a
video really easily and so uh you know
crypto gets a lot of for having
like oh there's no like use case for
this even though like you know money is
the main use case but they're like the
blockchain one of the other use cases
for blockchain and there's a really
interesting company that's doing
something in the space where they were
like hey um crypto has this really cool
thing where you have a private key you
have your own address that only you you
own and control and what what they
normally do is they say hey sign it to
do a transaction so if you want to send
money you sign it with your private key
that's how you authorize the transaction
so these guys what they realize is hey
there's now going to be so much video
out there and there's going to be a big
question of is this photoshopped is this
deep faked is this real or is this fake
and they were like people are going to
need people companies they're going to
need a way to authenticate or to sign a
piece of content and say this was real I
made this this is actually me um versus
the viewer having the putting the burden
on the viewer and be like can you tell
if this is real or fake it's like dude I
don't know it's too hard like
misinformation is going to spread so now
there's going to be like a watermark
that basically the Creator the original
owner the the person in question can use
their private key to sign and say yep
that was that was real that was me that
was my video or that was my my writing I
actually said that that's my voice I I
did say those words and it will become
true very soon that like if there's a
piece of content that's unsigned it's be
like y I don't you know I don't know
what this is this is this ain't organic
produce I don't know what this is this I
don't know where this came from um I
don't trust this and so I think that's
going to be one of the the the
consequence of let's say you see this
rise in generative AI as a trend you say
oh that's great people are going to
create all kinds of content but wait
that means we're not going to know
what's real and what's been generated by
AI we need a solution for that and I
think those guys are going to do pretty
well what's what's interesting about
this is not just the trends but the fact
that you're doing this and and I think
that that's kind of breaks uh a couple
rules or at least rules that people
think exist and a lot of people don't
know that Jeff Bezos story but basically
I think he I think the exact the exact
quote was pretty good it said something
like uh I saw the internet was growing
at 23 100% a year and I realized nothing
outside of of a petri dish grows that
fast and I just thought what can I sell
and well let's just start with books
because they're easy to ship and there's
a lot of them and so I can just pack
Amazon with almost every book I can find
and I think people will buy that um
whereas a lot of people think they have
to start a company because they have
like some passion about it or some
Mission which I actually think your
passion can develop once you start
working on it and it starts succeeding
um a have you thought about selling your
research process because that's actually
what I did with Trends and I and I made
a bunch of mistakes with that I should
have charged more maybe I shouldn't even
have done it in the first place but um a
what's your end goal with this with with
like your have you thought about making
my
mistake well that's what I heard it
could have done better I should have
charged 30,000 instead of or I should
have charged way differently that's
where I screwed up um but have you have
you thought about turning this into a
business the second question what is
your outcome with your second business
now that you have Financial Security and
uh like do you have like a legacy plan
do you have a number that you're working
back for back from what are you doing to
to decide which one to actually go
down yeah so I think that to answer the
first question I I've been asked because
we've talked about research stuff a lot
like either through DMs or on the last
pod like I think research companies they
have they have a fatal flaw where where
they give people a dopamine Rush of
understanding something but people are
pretty bad at then using that
information in some particular way so
like the retention ends up not being
great unless you turn into like a
McKenzie style like oh we trusted them
to come in and do this research and kind
of go from there so like even the
competitive Intel stuff like I I know
how to use that because I've been taught
how to use it and I've like developed it
people really like the dopamine of like
oh I can see exactly what's going on but
they don't know how to like get to the
next step so if I were to do it it would
be some sort of you know almost do it
for you not only in terms of the
research but then connecting that to
some sort of outcome where they can just
hook it up and then it targets their ads
or something um to actually get an
outcome so I can take the thought
process out of the um out of my
customer's you know particular um
evaluation of the product I think in
terms of the second question for me I'm
I'm like a cliche second time founder
now right so I'm basically like either
I'm going to go into like cash flowing
lifestyle style points type businesses
or I'm going to go into like big ass you
know Innovation type business and I
think the basis numbers piece is really
really powerful for the latter one
because you know you're looking at some
really big trends that probably have
some social and cultural like
implications but then you're also trying
to build like a particularly big
business which is what my intention is
essentially and I've done a lot of work
over the past year to kind of like come
to that realization with like coaches
and therapists and all that kind of fun
stuff so for me what I do is I look at
this and I don't know if the Bezos
number piece is is is necessarily like
useful to folks who aren't trying to
like build big I think it's really
useful for folks who want to do like
quick hits but I think like the next
framework that I kind of put in there
around like you know taking different
product ideas and then spinning them in
terms of different customer bases or
different like differentiators that's
what most people should be doing because
Innovation like a 10x better product is
almost impossible in this particular
environment now like 10 15 years ago you
could build an Innovative 10x better
product because you were the one that
had the special relationship with the
supplier in Yemen for the coffee or
something like that or you were the one
that only could build this particular
feature but now everyone in their mother
can spin up a website features are no
longer really defensible anymore and
unless you have like some sort of
patentable or some sort of scientific
kind of breakthrough or regulatory kind
of protection um your best thing you're
going to do is like a two or 3x better
product and um that's why I think it's
just one of those things that um you
know Innovation isn't something that you
should be targeting unless you're really
really going big is essentially what I'm
getting at why do you care about doing
the cash flow thing because many of our
friends Sean and I friends me and Sean's
friends and you I'm sure your buddies
are like this they're quite wealthy many
tens of millions or hundreds of millions
and they're like but I would love to
have $5 million a year of income I for
me and this is like very personal it's
not for everybody but like I discovered
in going through this like wave of like
massive wealth really quickly I
discovered that like like I'll give you
like a little bit of an anecdote so when
the money hit the bank account I felt
nothing like I was like happy I was like
obviously you know happy for the team
but the thing that like went into the
back of my head and I didn't know how to
express it in this particular way was
very much well if I did it it must not
have been that hard which goes into like
childhood it goes into a bunch of
different things and so when I'm
thinking about the next business I look
at those two paths right like there's
like more cash flowy business own your
own destiny lifestyle style points these
types of things and then I think that
there's like spending your time going
after something that's harder and harder
and trying to go after Innovation right
like the perfect like antithesis of how
I view the world now is like Nick Huber
right Nick is like why would you ever
try to like innovate that's like so much
harder Etc and we've had many like long
night conversations about that um and
for me it's like I want to go after that
bigger and bigger thing and it took it
took a long time to like realize that
cuz I went after like oh let's do this
let's do that let's do this other thing
let's go after this quick Buck you
bought 19 gas
stations I did buy 19 gas stations but
that's Jenny that's Jenny that's the
wife the wife handles the real estate
portfolio and it doesn't mean I'm not
going to like do stuff but like my
primary focus is going to be like one
big thing um I don't want to be an
investor I don't want to like come up
with a bunch of cash flowing like Studio
style businesses I I respect a hell out
of all those things it's just I just
found out it's not for me or at least
that's that's where I got to by by the
way could you tell us the gas station
thing real quick would you meet Sayad
and he told you about his gas station
portfolio so okay here's what happened
so I bought 19 gas stations um they're
in North and South Carolina you bought
them all at once or like one at a time
like you bought a chain all in one pot
so essentially there was there was a
kind of a patriarch of a family who had
built up a portfolio about 120 he passed
away and then um basically I think it
was the trust or the estate I don't know
which which but he was they were selling
them off in blocks right and they don't
want to sell off like one at a time cuz
it's 120 because the kids they had a tax
bill coming up because the inheritance y
y y so um this actually is is this
started with Nick Huber and Mitchell um
ball Bridge um of the ceg world because
they started talking to me about oh
there's there's some tax implications
where if if your partner your wife or
your husband is a real estate
professional your passive losses on like
real estate become active losses and
they offset active gains so got a big
pile of you know kind of gains from the
sale of the company and then all of a
sudden I can offset those with
depreciation of the gas stations and I
can do that with bonus depreciation in
one year so just to use some round
numbers like if I buy $10 million of gas
stations I basically can take eight
million of depreciation essentially and
that can offset some of those particular
gains and so in October September um
Nick starts telling me about this I
start talking to Mitchell trying to
figure it out I start talking to tax
lawyers all of a sudden we got intro to
someone who saw saw this deal of these
120 Jenny has been in the real estate
game for like 10 years and so it it's
one of those things we were able to kind
of like you know we weren't starting
from zero but it was still like a big
big purchase um and we closed I think
like December 23rd or something like
that so like right right at the
particular edge of the end of the year
to uh to not only get a good deal um
because we had you know we looked at the
real estate deal independent of the tax
implications but the tax implications
kind of put it over the top to be really
really good and has there been like are
is it just like wow this was a great
asset great smooth sailing or is it like
oh my God I have 19 pain in the asses
now or what's the what's the situ like
what's the verdict of guy who didn't own
real estate in gas stations like Tech
entrepreneur does this thing that has
clear benefits on the tax side might
have a might be a nice diversifying part
of my portfolio might be good cash flow
might also be a headache what's your
answer now that you've come out the
other side uh so they're triple net
leases so that basically means we don't
manage don't handle any operations
anything like that um they're owned by a
a big flag a big company um so they're
corporate backed which may or may not
mean anything depending on who you ask
in the real estate world so we've had
very little headaches um we also have a
partner on the deal who's you know we
were the money they're handling most
they handled all the analysis and all
that kind of fun stuff um so it's it's
been pretty smooth sailing I mean there
hasn't been any issues that's famous
last words I think um there's a way to
basically you know manage these into
more Investments and things like like
that those that's where it can get a
little tricky but like yeah we we got at
least knock on wood pretty lucky in
terms of what's going on but you got to
can you get can you give any numbers I
mean how much income is that bringing in
how much did it cost can can you give
any numbers on that do you feel
comfortable I can give you some numbers
so um well I don't know my wife runs it
so if you don't want to share the
specifics on yours you could just be
like you know I think about this way
like uh this business is a box like a
restaurant restaurant will typically
cost you say half a million to open and
then you're trying your goal is to n
150k a year per location you want to get
to 20 that's how you get scale like it's
simpler than that so it it's 30 million
in gas stations um I believe I I can't
remember the exact cap rate um basically
what we're getting out of it but we're
getting um I believe the Caps are at
like five and a half um and so we're not
getting like an IM like an immense
amount of income from that um but we are
getting income basically from it and
then the leases on this particular deal
made it so great is um all of the like
rent increases were based off of CPI and
they were they were written in like the
early 2000s so basically what's
happening is as you've seen all the
inflation data when these rent increases
go into effect the increase in rent is
pretty significant um and so that's what
made the deal really really good but
like yeah we're we're cash flowing I
don't know it's it's it's definitely
over a million a year on these um I
don't know the exact numbers um which I
feel good about because it's one of
those things where I trust my wife to
figure it out and you also said that
there was like you you sell the company
and you're like uh you go through this
wandering phase for like a year uh you
said there's five phases what are the
five phases of I just sold my company
for a bunch of money yeah this is like
the the champagne problem cycle I think
and it's it it's just this crazy roller
coaster and I don't know Sam Sean if you
guys went through this but for me like I
was pretty even keeled emotionally
before the actual sale what I mean by
that is like something bad would happen
to the business I'd be like oh that
sucks okay let's figure it out something
good I'd be like oh great but we have
all these other problems um when the
sale goes through especially if it's
like announced like everyone kind of
starts treating you like a god for like
a hot second and then that leavs you to
go like wait am I a God right you have
this little bit of this like almost this
like impostor like I don't know what
reverse impostor syndrome is and like I
never got like I have good friends
around me who are like yeah you your
your still stinks but like it was
one of those funny things where you're
just like oh my God I can do anything
and then like you go through the second
phase which is like oh my God I fear
death I'm going to screw this up I'm
going to like I don't know how to Rich
how does one rich correctly I'm going to
lose it all and this is when you're like
tax lawyers accountants other lawyers
how do I evaluate how they're good or
not like all these crazy thing what is a
wealth manager like oh my God the wealth
managers every single one of them tells
you just put it in index funds and then
you ask them well then what's your job
and then they're like oh we just advise
you and you're like okay what does that
mean and they can't answer the question
so do you get one do you not get one
right and then um you start to get a
handle on things you start to kind of
like Get Your Feet Under you you buy a
bunch of gas stations you do this type
of a thing and then like phase three is
like or like part of phase three is like
I call this the delusional peak of
cocaine energy and this is like you have
all this energy and you're like I'm
going to do everything right this is
what I was getting into a Sam before
it's like I'm going to hire 19 people or
not 19 17 people it's 19 gas station 17
people to do research to look into
things to go look at this deal to go
look at that deal and just like do all
of these things and I'm going to build
this and I'm going to build that because
you just have this all this energy and
this optionality um and that leads to
just a full-blown identity crisis um and
so I hired a couple of shrinks um to
basically help because you know it was a
major change in my life and you know
just kind of a major thing where like
it's kind of like you know figuring out
like who you are what you want which I
kind of talked about a little bit before
and starting to realize like oh like I
don't have to do these things I can do
these things what do I want to do um
what does that look like and then you
know then you kind of even out and you
go back to the Grind so that was like my
last year of just up down down even
further and then kind of back up to
figuring out like hey this is what I
want um and kind of going from there you
even did this cool study or this survey
where you talked to didn't you survey a
bunch of people who are wealthy and you
asked them about happiness and things
like that yeah this is how I cope with
things research as you clearly can see
so I spent 50 Grand on like a study
basically running and this is one of our
products at profa well was like
basically running research studies um
and so I spent 50 Grand basically trying
to get in front of as many like Rich
folks as humanly possible um and then
doing a bunch of qualitative
conversations with like you know you
know number of billionaires a bunch of
like sentim millionaires Etc and just
trying to figure out like okay what what
makes them happy what makes them unhappy
so that I can you know kind of some of
those lessons for for me personally what
what were the lessons one of the biggest
lessons that I think is most helpful and
I don't know if everyone's going to be
able to like hear it they or they'll
hear it but I don't know if they'll
actually like internalize it is when you
look at the stack of like how money can
actually bring happiness um there are
some really really obvious things like
um people who spend money on stuff they
are happier than people who don't spend
money on stuff but they're not as happy
as the people who spend money on like a
particular hobby or particular like
narrowing of stuff so buying a Birkin
bag that you guys talked about I think
last episode like that brings some Joy
it actually does it's not something
that's like completely joyless but if
you're really into F1 and you buy your
own car that you go race in the track
that brings you more happiness right and
then one layer above that in terms of
increasing even more happiness is
experiences so this is something that
we've all heard about like buying
experience actually does bring more
happiness and what was really
interesting were the top two one is
really really obvious so above
experiences was like giving money away
in like a targeted way not just like
General like here you go this um
organization or this nonprofit but like
actually giving it to a cause that you
really cared about but the top one was
kind of fascinating like the things that
we coded that built or brought the most
happiness were what I kind of labeled
Freedom inducing events or Freedom
inducing items so things like a jet if
you you can afford a jet and you can fly
private it's not the nature of the jet
it's that it brings you so much freedom
and so we saw this kind of coded in all
the responses and so things like I know
Sam you've been a little hesitant to it
things like getting a personal assistant
things like getting someone to take care
of stuff at the home those things
actually bring a lot more happiness
because unless you really really like
buying the groceries or doing something
like that that brings more freedom and
that that actually increases happiness
levels even more than all the other
things that we talked about um the other
big thing that was really interesting is
that um the the happiness scales that
you see kind of online in those studies
um for both income and net worth like
typically they can't they're I
I they're limited that's what I would
say um like meaning like um they
basically are like oh 75,000 your
happiness doesn't increase and then
there was another study that found
enough people you know up to about a
half million where happiness increased
well I took it all the way to I think
it's like 3 to four million a year and
the happiness just continues to increase
it's not at the same rate but like more
income and more net worth does bring
more happiness like I'm not sure where
it's going to like level off but right
now in my data on net worth I have a a
good enough sample that I can actually
map it from zero to about 50 million um
in net worth um but the one really
interesting thing was no matter the net
worth um particularly for the folks who
had more than 5 to 10 million in net
worth um no matter what it was if it was
higher and some of the billionaires
qualitatively this was also the case um
you would see that if the net worth went
up they got happier if the net worth
stayed the same they were a little bit
happier if the net worth went down even
just like a minuscule amount that the
like the the reduction in happiness was
considerable and so it's one of those
things where it's like when you get
wealthy it's like all about protect
protect protect that's you know for a
lot of obvious mathematical reasons but
also from a happiness perspective that's
where a lot of like the anxiety was
coming from from some of the the more
wealthier folks um there's a couple
other things oh like this was really
fascinating because this was like a
little more personable um of wealthy
folks let's just say I think it was like
folks over 5 million in net worth um but
it continued the trend even higher um
there were only a couple of like trends
that everyone did like almost every
single person not 100% but like you know
let's just say 90ish percent plus um
lists was a big thing like lists or like
a to-do list of some sort um wealthy
folks almost to a had some sort of
system where every day they were like
here's what I'm going to do for some it
was like I got one big thing each day
for others it was like some hardcore
like to-do list app and all this other
fun stuff that was organized but that
was a really big thing um everyone's
still in the game meaning still building
a business still trying to build their
wealth worked out or had some sort of
Fitness regularly folks out of the game
they started to kind of like fall off on
that particular Fitness but like 90% of
people like it wasn't they're all doing
CrossFit or all doing anything crazy but
a lot of them were doing um at least
something consistently every single week
um so that was really really fascinating
to see as well there were a couple other
things that were like pretty consistent
but um those were the really really big
ones that stood out that would be most
helpful I think to folks I have a nerdy
question about the happiness thing how
do you what what is the actual like how
do you know how happy somebody is how do
they know how happy they are so are you
just saying how happy are you did you
get happier when you got more money it's
like a self-reported like 1 to 10 thing
or is there a better way that people ask
that question
yeah totally so my instinct is to like
teach stats right now so I'm going to
try to avoid that as much as humanly
possible um but that you don't when we
look at like temperature just trust me
for a second like we can get very very
accurate readings on like how cold it is
in your apartment right now or your
house right now right and we can be very
very confident in that particular like
measurement right now we can also get
the temperature measurement by like
maybe measuring the outside temperature
and subtracting what we think the
insulation is of your house and trying
to figure out like in a backwards way
that would be less accurate than like
measuring the actual temperature but
still more accurate than if I went and I
asked you what you thought the
temperature was right and there's
different ways that I can ask you
temperature right if I just straight up
ask you what's the temperature it's like
it's actually kind of a difficult
question for you to answer but if I ask
you do you think it's more than 68
degrees it's a little bit easier for you
to answer so there's different ways to
answer these questions now what that
means is and the way reason I gave that
little metaphor is like there's we're
not looking at measuring temperature
like the way that we would in a very
scientific way like we just can't do
that because like happiness it is
relative there's a bunch of different
factors but that doesn't mean we can't
like measure it purely right so what I
did and um I'll try to like keep this as
as helpful as possible is um I looked at
how the $75,000 study does and and there
is a happiness kind of research center
there's a number of different actually
the first undergrad research I ever did
was how do tax rates impact happiness um
in in the economics Department in school
and so there's different ways to ask it
so the way that this was asked there's a
number of different ways there was a
scoring system there was a this happened
how does that affect your happiness so
there's a composite score that we kind
of put together based on those different
inputs to come up with essentially
here's what their happiness level is
comparatively and then you keep that
consistent across the board um and
there's ways you can adjust the model um
but long story short like it's it's the
way I describe temperature it's a little
bit closer to like hey what do you think
your temperature is so it's not dude I
think that's just fascinating I think
it's incredibly fascinating and I think
it's amazing that you're doing this uh
you I like seeing your nerd come out I I
think it's this is very this is very
cool yeah yeah I got really excited I
felt my heart rate just go up there
sorry I think Sam Sam hit the nail on
the head where he's like uh these things
you said are interesting but what's more
interesting is that you did this and uh
you know you were just describing like
people spend on stuff but they're more
happy if they spend on a targeted set of
stuff yeah that's you spending 50 Grand
on a study about wealth right that's you
you don't have a model train hobby you
have a research Hobby and you were like
oh how do I use these funds to scratch
my itch in a way that I haven't done
before and I'm sure that it was like it
wasn't the takeaways from the study
probably it was doing the study that
actually made you happier and and felt
like a good use of your time um I'll
also say like uh you know a lot of
people listen to this podcast will
probably be probably make this mistake
and so I'll say it out loud cuz I made
the mistake which was I thought my goal
was I don't want to be rich I Want to Be
Free right I think that's a common thing
people say makes themselves feel feel a
little bit better than I'm just chasing
money say no I'm chasing freedom and
it's true like it is better to Chase
Freedom than than money uh but I thought
you know there's a number and I remember
thinking uh when I was like maybe 26 27
I was like oh you told me it was 6
million right yeah I was like $6 million
that's my freedom number and I I like I
was focused on six as my fre Freedom
number I even had it in my passwords it
would be like a six in there cuz I was
like every time I log in I want to be
thinking about that number and that's
how I was thinking about things I passed
that number and I was like well uh all
right was my math wrong or is this
concept of a freedom number wrong and I
had a very simple realization which was
that being financially free doesn't mean
you have a certain amount of money in
your bank account it means you are now
free from money owning you and that is a
decision you make and so for example the
the simple test is um how much of how
much of what you do is because of money
and somebody who's truly absolutely
Financial financially free they do not
make a choice based on money so that
could be they buy something and oh why'
you buy why do you shop at this grocery
store even it's more expensive well
because I'm not making my decision based
on money it could be um a job you why do
you why are you working on this oh
because I think it's going to have a big
payoff or I think the salary the salar
is you know too good toay pass up well
you're making a decision based on money
and the true Financial Freedom isn't on
some number it's when you can get to the
point where you stop making choices that
are based on money which is half mindset
at least 50% mindset if not 80% mindset
and maybe the remainder is an actual you
know uh Financial reality of how much
money how much money you have in your
bank account I would I would edit that
very slightly and it's almost
semantic
I I think it's it's almost it's a a
function of force rather than um choice
so what I mean by that is there are a
lot of people myself included who are
still making decisions with money in
mind right because to me there are
certain goals that I have that are
probably going to change as I get nearer
to them not just for a number's sake
like I'm not one of those people who
which I I don't judge but like there are
people who just want the number to
continue to go up right there's other
folks and I count myself as one of them
is like I want ever increasing um waves
of like Freedom the ability to do stuff
and money unlocks that ability so I
still make decisions based off of it but
I don't have to right like I can
rationalize as to why I don't want to so
I just found that there's still a lot of
people who have like there's this
billionaire who I was talking to about
this and we were we were basically
having coffee and you know he's going
through like he's he's still in the game
he sounds just like us he's still like
oh yeah I'm going to go do this I'm
going to go do this like the stakes are
different the numbers are different and
some of them the moves are very
different
but I asked him I was like so why like
you don't need to do any of this right
but it seems like you don't want to do
this decision but it's going to net the
most money for you in this particular
situation so like why do you want to do
this and his answer was basically what I
was just saying which is like well if I
get another billion I can go do this
thing and his thing was like this
nonprofit thing that he kind of wanted
to do and so does he actually believe
that I have no idea right I can't read
his mind but like for me the idea of
like okay I can buy 19 gas stations i'
i' like to buy a skyscraper next do I
need a skyscraper no do I want a
skyscraper not really but I like the
idea that I can right but you realize
that sounds totally ridiculous right
like if I understand it sounds
ridiculous right like one of my one of
my goals one something this is gonna
sound crazy and this is the perfect the
perfect audience to say this but like I
get so jacked up about the idea of like
toppling a DI dictatorship one day I get
so excited by it and I'm like I'm not
even kidding and I'm like okay well if
we if we go after Cuba it's going to
cost this much because I have this idea
and this idea that have you you've done
research on this you have spreadsheets
that 100% yeah well how much does it
cost in which order of countries do you
put like what's like your top three of
like yeah I don't want to name I don't
want to name countries quite yet because
I think that that like could get me in a
little bit of trouble and also like
again my point is more like will I ever
actually do this I have no idea but it
gets me
Sobe I think I think that there there
are certain countries that I think are
in really really Dire Straits that I
think like 3 400 million you could
really really make a dent and it
wouldn't involve like doing anything
like crazy legal or anything like that
it would involve basically uh um because
if you think about if you really want to
nerd out on this which I don't think you
want to but it's like countries breathe
with their GDP right the money coming in
the money going out Etc so when you look
at that as like an access that you can
attack um there's so much you can do um
and that doesn't even get into like
stuff you can do with social media with
the actual like you know people we
haven't even mentioned murder
yet no no no yeah yeah you're the second
successful entrepreneur I've met who has
researched this and has serious they
haven't seriously considered it because
they're not there yet but they're like
you know I think I could take over
Bangladesh uh like like I don't want to
take it over I'm not going to install
myself as a leader or anything I just
want to like genuinely help right like
he wants to better the place like look
at Cuba like Cuba you know it's one of
those things where it's like it's been
been problematic you know a problematic
state for a long time part of that's our
fault as the United States another part
of that's just you know the people who
um governed it but like I think it'd be
really cool to like basically free Cuba
people people can't even free the city
of San Francisco right now like they're
trying to they're trying to get the
mayor you know to actually like you know
enforce uh you know punishment on crimes
or they tried to recall Gavin Newsome I
think it is a lot tougher than you think
but it's surprising how many uh you know
I guess like the the game from you know
sort of wealth to status to power uh you
know it's it is interesting to see how
many people end up in the power game um
it's not a like I I want to be clear
it's not a it's it's not a uh it's
actually more of like a social
entrepreneurship thing than it is
anything yeah no that's not true dude
that is not true no it is I gu I okay
I've done the work I've done the
introspection yeah well like like the
debate you're having in your head like
it's basically like if you are Mark
Benny off and you create the Benny off
hospital and say San Francisco what
ratio is because you want the mark
bending off hospital or because you want
to cure cancer and I don't think it's
wrong that it's higher on the I want my
name on it it's not wrong if there was a
pie chart right there's like the
challenge of it the intellectual
stimulation and the challenge that's
definitely one uh there's the impact and
the wanting to do good in the world
that's two there's the bragging rights
SL power game of like yeah I did that
um you know like I helped do that
that's what I did with my my my time my
talents my my money I think there's some
combination whatever the combination is
I don't think it's zero on all the other
things but there's a really big
difference right there's a really big
difference right so like I am I'm as
close to nihilist as like I think one
can get without being a full-blown
nihilist because I just from from a just
the way my brain's wired if I was like a
nihilist I just would be like well I'm I
don't know if I'm going to be a net
positive therefore like nothing matters
Etc so to me it's like you get to design
the game right you get to design the
game that you want and when I look at
like spending money to put your name on
something it does feel kind of like a
waste I don't I don't like at least
personally like I haven't had my name on
anything I don't really get excited
about that but what I do get excited
about is like the challenge part and
then yeah like oh I you know if I could
be the person who did X like that is
really really interesting right like
that is interesting but it's not like a
it's not it's not this like this this uh
I want to name a journalist who has a
very cynical view of our industry but
it's not like this like you know cynical
View
it's not this like oh I need to you know
have a dick measuring contest or
something like that like that's that's
not how I think about it and that's why
like I think that like doing stuff in
San Francisco I think some of the worst
days in San Francisco are still better
than some of the other stuff that's
happening in the world right and so
that's why like looking globally I think
are really really fascinating I think
after this podcast you're going to be
adding a third shrink to the
payroll yeah probably probably just
based on this yeah yeah yeah you have
two other really interesting things that
you s over want to I want to hit so one
is you had this remix framework that you
kind of talked about earlier but I want
to like double down and we should put
the slide up on YouTube because it's
hard to describe it's too it's too much
to describe but the slide makes it
really easy so you basically were like
look Innovation you know maybe you're
not like all Innovation nor are you Nick
Huber you know Innovation is a waste of
time you're kind of like your goal is to
you know I don't know you you could say
this but you want to take a product and
you want to remix it that's one way to
think about how to up with a novel
business uh opportunity is to remix an
existing one and you had these remixes I
thought the good example was you took
consumer products and you were like if
you take it and you make it cheaper
that's a way to differentiate um through
better supply chain you could take it
and you could say I'm going to align it
with a celebrity that's a differentiator
and you got like you have the example
here of febles with Mr Beast you have um
you can alignment with a lifestyle like
keto or Christian or hunting and you
have like Yeti Coolers here um yeah
science backed you have another one
that's like you align it with a uh an
identity like a political party or LGBT
or you have here as the example Black
Rifle coffee so does this first talk
about this and then is this only for
Consumer products or does this work
across the board in your opinion so here
here's where this comes from so we had
50,000 different there are subscription
companies but 50,000 companies using our
financial analytics um and we were
helping them with pricing their turn and
and giving them this this data and they
were from Ross the map B2B SAS
subscription nonprofits D Toc was one of
our big segments and I started to notice
that like for just under 10,000 of these
DDC Brands The Playbook was almost the
same over and over and over again right
like it wasn't like there was some
innovation in creating mattresses it was
literally like we will be cheaper
through better supply chain and we will
help the environment and maybe we donate
money to people who don't have beds
right like it was just over and over and
over again so I wanted to create
essentially a unified theory of like
creating products right and so I I
shared the consumer one because that's
probably the easiest one to talk about
but there's just there's only 10 things
that these Brands differentiate on and
there number of the things that you
talked about and my point around
Innovation is that like don't try to
necessarily innovate maybe don't even
try to like raise money for any of these
types of like consumer ideas because all
you really need to do is take a
particular product and then remix it
with some of these differentiators right
so for example like you mentioned Black
Rifle coffee that's basically aligning
with an identity right so Black Rifle
you know it's guns it's rightwing it's
veterans it's all these other fun things
well identity based products increase
willingness to pay by about 20 to 40% so
if I just had regular coffee and then I
had regular Co or I had regular coffee
that was built particularly for this
like we'll just say like conservative
but I don't think they necessarily claim
that party all of a sudden that coffee
is worth 20 to 40% because you're
niching down into that particular group
so I put together together these 10
things and also the the data around
increased willingness to pay but for
example if I was a you know particular
entrepreneur who didn't necessarily like
want to necessarily innovate which most
people shouldn't um I might go and be
like cool well I like coffee I think
coffee is great I think I get really
excited about that what's a what's
another lifestyle right so creating woke
roast right coffee for the left
basically um where all of a sudden you
could have coffee you know basically for
that particular identity and people
flock in your retention is typically
much much higher when you do this as
well um it's something that really works
right um I had a friend a really good
friend who wanted to create a business
um he's involved in the LGBT community
so we talked about kambucha specifically
for the gay community calling it bubbles
for bottoms which was kind of a fun name
um and so it just one of those things
where it's like creating this like
product remix and you can do this in a
bunch of different ways like you could
be the premium version of whatever
you're actually selling um you know
chinola right it's watches it's
notebooks Etc but they're Premium versus
you know some of the other stuff that's
out there you have here uh you have
Health Plus lifestyle athletic greens
for dogs condoms Plus organic materials
week yeah organic condoms they're just
goingon to sell you a package with
nothing in it that's the organic condom
that's basically natur all natural I
didn't think of that that's good made
out air I like that honestly I bet you
could sell that that's liquid death
right liquid death is water in a in a
mean looking can I think you could
probably sell uh like an all natural
condom uh that's just nothing uh you
could literally so let do it the natural
way yeah yeah there's a way yeah you got
to look at it's like sustainable right I
don't know a lot about the sexual
Wellness Market but it's like yeah long
story short like it it doesn't have to
be complicated the effort and the
execution is really really hard but the
ideation doesn't have to be that hard
did you make this chart this is really
good this is great where did this come
from yeah so this is this is based on
like probably collecting I don't know I
don't know the number but it's hundreds
of thousands of willingness to pay data
points cuz we did the pricing I don't
know if you guys even know that we've
never talked about pricing that was like
my core thing that's what I was most
well known for in the SAS Community um
so we did the pricing for like Blue
Bottle Coffee we did lifts pricing we
did a bunch other like B2B style pricing
so we have a lot of data in the pricing
space and when I say we did it it's like
we might have done it or we might have
helped them do it depends on the company
if you had to summarize your learnings
with pricing is there like two or three
bullet points where you'd be like just
do these three things and you're 90%
there sort of um but with like giving
you a little bit more bulleting um you
should be changing something about your
price every 3 months that does not mean
raise your price every three months but
it means like changing up your packaging
going up Market down Market changing up
an add-on changing up your discounting
strategy it's this forgotten growth
lever in most businesses you acquire
customers you monetize them retain them
we focus probably 60% of most budgets
more so in D Toc less so in B2B on like
basically acquiring customers we spend a
little bit of time on retention we spend
like no time on pricing so change
something every three months um one of
the biggest hacks that's easy to talk
about on a podcast add-ons um they're
the most underrated underutilized aspect
of all pricing consumer B2B Enterprise
um they boost lifetime value by about 20
to 50% so just to make sure this is
clear like hey they bought your core
product which is a fitness shirt well
add a white T-shirt for $10 like stuff
like that those are like add-ons hey
they bought your SAS app add priority
support for whatever 10% of your list
price is for the the software um most
companies like the most high growth
companies at least in the subscription
space they have 12 or more add-ons
typically customer never sees them all
at all 12 of them but they'll see like
one or two of them and then one other
really quick hack is um localization
this doesn't work for every company but
like internationalizing your pricing so
the nordics um you know when we take
into account exchange rates and stuff
like that they're still willing to pay
about 30% higher than the US for the
exact same product um folks in like
southeast Asia it's about 40% less
there's a really large variance on that
um but that's a really quick thing where
you can boost typically your Revenue per
customer by about 15 20% literally by
just like changing what the pricing
looks like depending on where they come
in um across the world dude you're inle
as fascinating yeah that was good
uh you also said a really good thing in
in the the sheet here that you didn't
say which was how do you measure if your
pricing changes like a good change or a
bad change right how do you know um how
do you know if you did it right what's
the metric you choose yeah it's it's
it's Revenue per customer which is going
to be different for every company so in
your business if you're doing pricing
properly that Revenue per customer
number should be going up into the right
so like arpo ARA ACV however you're
measuring it um that that should be
going up um and now it's not going up as
fast as your sales or as some of your
other numbers but like you should if
you're changing something about your
pricing every three months you should
basically be seeing that number go up I
don't know it's hard to give like a
benchmark because later stage it goes up
slower but it should just be going up
every single year if not every six
months is that assuming you have free
and paid as a mix because like for
example if I'm at Ecom store I could
quadruple my
prices I would make more money per
customer but I would just have less
customers and less money overall if I
did that right because Ecom like you
know for example what we use is uh
Revenue per visitor which is like uh for
for if somebody hits the site how much
do we make $2 off them a dollar off them
for every average Customer because that
takes into account conversion rate and
how much they spend when they
convert yeah so I would say and you can
get into like cart average cart those
types of things I think that as you get
more sophisticated in how you think like
for example like for an e-commerce world
I would probably want to look at like
maybe lifetime like dollars in like that
average number going up because what
that means theoretically is assuming
revenues going up and all those numbers
are great that means like I'm monetizing
better right so it's not necessarily in
a vacuum right like if my Revenue per
customer goes up you know a THX but I
don't have any other customers obviously
that's not great but it's one of those
things where most people again they
don't like like the average like people
don't it's it's kind of crazy like it
takes when we looked at how often people
raise their prices so you should be
raising your price at least once per
year um there are some top outs and
there's some exceptions to this
particular rule but everything about
your price is basically this exchange
rate on your value so like you've
created this value and because you know
we don't trade goat for wheat anymore
you're basically saying this value is
worth this much dollars right and so
it's that exchange rate and there's a
bunch of things that influence that like
your brand um the quality of the product
who which customer you're going after
like some customers will value your
product higher and so if your product is
improving every single year your Brand's
improving you should be able to demand
higher prices but most people I think
the average amount of time they take
between pricing changes like actual
price increases like three years and
I've seen so many because they're
because they're fearful because the CEO
is fearful they're scared is that the
that's is that like 80% of the issue
they're just scared it's just scared
yeah and and we tried to fill this Gap
with our pricing product and we still do
because it just gives them confidence
because we're like all right here's data
that says you sat in a room when you
founded the company and said ah base
camp does 50 bucks let's just do 50
bucks to and then you never Revisited
that like for years we have this data
that says you can actually charge this
customer 500 this customer 100 and we're
going to like roll it out in like a nice
way just for new customers first and all
of a sudden your conversion goes up and
your Revenue per customer goes up and
you're really excited um and then all of
a sudden you're like confident enough to
basically put that for your existing
customers as well um so yeah I think
that's it's just a lot of fear you get
all these like I've been in so many like
so many exec teams with this product
where it's like the smartest people I've
ever met just sitting there and like if
I give them any other in their business
they're like okay um I'm not an engineer
but like let's figure it out what's a
what's a stack what is this like they'll
go like attack it you give them pricing
and they're all like I don't know what
do you think what do you think because
it touches every area of the business
and they just lack that that confidence
in looking at it and so I I think like
starting off with like let's introduce
an add-on let's introduce some of this
stuff that's typically like the gateway
to oh this pricing stuff works let's you
know let's Lise our prices and I have a
I have an email that I've um I've
basically cultivated over the past
decade for like changing prices I'm
happy to share it and we can put in the
show notes or I'll throw it on Twitter
where it's literally like just steal the
template like T-Mobile used it they
stole it from the website and they used
it which was kind of fun to see um but
it basically just goes through like how
to communicate a price increase um the
tldrs don't make it about you make it
about them um because they don't care
about your costs or whatever they care
about their costs and that's the biggest
mistake most people make but yeah I'll
share that you're uh you're this is very
insightful you're very fascinating uh
you have a lot of really interesting
insights and I think you approach things
in a really cool way where you have a
good amount of self deprecating humor
but also like academic rigor you're
you're a fascinating person so are we
gonna is that mean we're going to do the
skin to- skin bonding now or is that
later lat in the podcast is that bro
what I I told Sean the same thing pop
the top baby come on let's go let's go
cheek to I'm losing weight so I don't I
don't feel uncomfortable taking my shirt
off yeah you've lost 40 pounds right
yeah yeah I'm down like probably about
90 total but 40 since I saw you guys um
wow and as Gucci M once said money makes
you handsome so like all cliche post
exit Founders I have to get healthier
and uh basically take it seriously what
what's been the the number one driver
just eating less or what uh I use my
body tutor so I know you're big fan of
that I don't know if Sean you're still
using it um Sean you're using it yeah I
went back to it and I'm having such a
good time the key was doing the uh call
The Daily call I do the daily call yeah
basic we have to tell people it's my
body tutor so basically it's like the
simplest thing ever we don't get paid
for this there's no I don't at least s
maybe you do but I I don't get paid for
this I I talk about conly they said
eventually if I tweeted about it I sent
a bunch of people and they're like hey
we'll give you a little bit of money but
I don't care if don't even mention me
when you use them I don't give a
but basically it's uh it's a 650 a month
and they call you daily and it's like a
five minute call and they're like why
did you eat this you're too fit let the
fat guys talk for a second here all
right go
ahead dek you Sean I didn't want say
anything nobody wants to hear the
shredded guy talk about
this yeah I'm down to like 2% body fat
I'm still experimenting with OIC it's
not a big deal if you're in a spot where
you feel a little shitty about yourself
you're like all right I'm overweight I
know this was completely in my control
and you've done all the things you've uh
listen to the podcast you got your
Andrew huberman's got you injecting
sunlight into your eyes in the morning
and you you've you've tried keto you
tried paleo you did all the right
and none of it's working or it all kind
of worked and actually the problem was
not in the plans it was all you to begin
with what my body tutor did was smart
which was they realized it's not the
diet that's the problem it's you
sticking to the diet that's the problem
as we all actually know deep down inside
and so they help you with that root
cause which is how do they hold you
accountable and help you actually stick
to the thing you actually want to know
they do give you some strategy along the
way they do give you some helpful um
ways to think about things I I give you
a very simple example Haley was like um
hey when you eat um I want you to take
note for a second like on a scale of 1
to five one being like I'm totally
satisfied five being I'm like ravenously
hungry right now where where are you
when you sat down for that meal if
you're eat sitting down at 5es the
problem was like we spaced out these
meals the wrong way or we're not getting
the right meals in and you're not
expected to have good willpower when
you're just like completely ra
ravenously hungry and so like we want to
be eating at a three um we want to leave
it at like you know you know we want to
leave the meal also not completely
stuffed you want to leave at at about a
three to two or three like you want get
in and just get your meal that way
you're just fueling upus like you know
going to this like feeding frzy so
there's little mindset tips but more
than anything it's you get a call in the
morning and she's like so what's the
plan for today eating wise you're like I
don't know I'm just going to eat
everything I see I guess oh wait no
that's not the right answer hold on uh
I'll eat at these times I'll eat these
meals no I I think the only thing I
would ask is like or um also add
is it health is in your control like if
you're listening to this like
you know unless you have like an obvious
like disability or something like that
like health is very much in your control
and what I love about my body tutor is
it kind of cuts through the BS I ask
Kaye about all these like esoteric
things like hey I read about this like
you know the cold plunging movement and
she's just like Fitness strength
training wh which country should I take
over
Haley Haley and I don't have that
relationship but no I think it's um I I
I just think it's one of those things
where we're bombarded with a lot of like
either quick fix or very marginal stuff
like even the the you know I I'm a big
humman fan uh Sam you tweeted recently
you would I also would like that's you
know he's he's he's a very very uh
awesome guy but I think it's one of
those things where a lot of that stuff
like unless you have the basics in place
it doesn't matter and so Haley like has
kept me accountable and like no no no no
we're gonna we're going to do pelaton
today we're going to do this we're going
to do
it's not even anything she says that
keeps you accountable it's just saying
the out loud and you're like
actually what the am I talking
about never mind sorry uh apologize well
for me it's been it's been like a you
know probably a year-long journey and it
was it started off with like you know
basically just breaking all these
conventions like Sean you were saying
where it's like oh I can't like BS
myself out of doing the right thing here
because I'm gonna have to talk to Haley
tomorrow about it and she's gonna not be
like sympathetic she's going to be like
why'd you do that and she's like you
shouldn't do that and I'm like yeah I
know and it's like cool let's not do it
tomorrow which which is you know
obviously really helpful we appreciate
you coming on man you're super
insightful um you're always fun to talk
to uh I don't remember the last time you
came but uh I feel like this time uh
definitely probably kicked its ass
because this was a 10 awesome that's my
goal in life I'm not Jesse I'm not all
these fancy people I got to bring the
noise that's the goal all right go
follow him on Twitter he's at pakus yeah
we appreciate you that's the
[Music]
pod